OK, saddle your horse
and harness your chaos
it's time for
another Beginner's Guide.
Now we're talking!
Sit back and relax as
we tell you everything you need
to know about
The Witcher: Blood Origin.
Skills.
So you know
how everyone keeps
banging on about this
Conjunction of the Spheres.
Conjunction.
Yes, I've read books before.
Well not everyone has, Geralt!
Explain.
To do that, we have to go back.
Way back.
Welcome to
twelve hundred years ago,
a time before
monsters, witchers and humans.
Yep, even the sexy ones.
This was the time of the elves.
History is all around us, brother.
So across the Continent
we have three elven kingdoms
at constant
war with each other.
And yes, I know
we have dwarves but -
Your world is
built on our bones.
Well, that is not good.
The time of the
spheres is upon us.
Shit!
Suddenly, for reasons
I don't want to spoil here,
those three kingdoms
well, they're
no longer with us -
leaving the Continent in
flux and a monster on the loose.
A monster.
How can that even exist?
Not only does it exist,
it looks like this rag tag crew
is going to have to go and kill it.
This is insane.
So how do they
kill this monster?
Where did it come from?
In the sky, a great beast
Will they need to create
a monster to kill a monster?
How do they
rate their chances?
We're fucked.
Will there be
more chat about destiny?
This is my destiny.
Destiny.
Fuck destiny.
Will there be more violence?
Well, it is the Witcher.
What is the Conjunction
of the Spheres anyway?
And do all these
questions get answered
in the plot of Blood Origin?
Yes, yes they do.
Oh, well I guess I'll
just watch that then eh.